MARK MANDEL: We got one minute.
I'm trying to work out the
safest place to put this.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: You don't
have the presentation here.
MARK MANDEL: No.
It's there.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Did you
click that YouTube thing?
MARK MANDEL: All right.
Let's get this started.
Doors are shut?
Excellent.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Mark Mandel.
I am a developer advocate
for Google Cloud Platform.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: And
I'm Gustavo Ambrozio.
I'm the lead developer for
War Dragons at Pocket Gems.
MARK MANDEL: Welcome
to Scaling Mobile Games
to a Global Audience using App
Engine and Cloud Datastore.
Possibly the longest
title here at this event.
You could probably
also rename this
as "Building games
without DevOps."
That would probably be
quite appropriate, as well.
So what are we going
to talk about today?
Well, we're going to talk about
a game called War Dragons.
And thanks, Gustavo, so
much for coming by today
to talk to us about that.
We really appreciate it.
So we're going to
go through what
that game is, have a look
at it, it's pretty awesome.
I like it a lot.
We're going to look at how its
backend infrastructure works.
So obviously this
is a Cloud event.
We want to look at
backend infrastructure.
We want to see what's
going on there.
We're going to talk
about what worked well.
What were the success stories?
What were the great
things that happened?
And we're also going
to look at some
of the problems they faced.
What lessons have been learned.
What can we teach
you about building
backend infrastructures for
this sort of application.
Finally we'll put a bow on
it, reach a nice conclusion,
and that will be the
end of the session.
Sound good?
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO:
Sounds awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
So let's get started.
War Dragons.
It's a great game.
I've played it.
I really enjoy it.
Gustavo, do you want to
tell us a little bit more
about what the game's all about?
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Sure thing.
So War Dragons is our highly
polished, 3D, real time
strategy mobile
game where you go
to collect and control
hundreds of dragons
to take out enemy bases.
In short, you get to control
a lot of very awesome looking
dragons and blow
up a lot of stuff.
It was Pocket Gem's
first 3D game.
It was our first game to
have synchronous, real time,
multiplayer battles.
And our first game to
come out like on day one
with a lot of social features.
So features such as
guilds, multiple chatrooms,
leaderboards, wars,
and much more.
So you can see that
in that respect
it was one game that put a lot
more pressure on our servers
than any other games
that we had before.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks for that.
So the first question
I have for you is,
like, why did you build
a multiplayer game?
You could have built
a game that was just
on a mobile device,
no interconnectivity,
but you decided to
build a game where
people could battle each other
and there was a backend and all
that sort of stuff.
What was the deal there?
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: So when we
started developing War Dragons
two years ago, we
saw an opportunity
to build something that nobody
has built before on mobile.
So there were a lot of games
out there where you can battle
other people's bases, but
it was always asynchronous--
like somebody can attack your
base but you cannot defend
yourself as they
are attacking you.
There was nothing like that
on the market at that point.
And we saw that
opportunity and we
knew that we can do
something like that.
We also saw the opportunity
to build something in 3D,
which we also never did before.
We saw that the market
was right and the devices
were right for that
at that moment.
MARK MANDEL: Now hold
on just a second.
Is that you over on the
right hand side there?
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Oh, yeah.
That third character.
Thank you for recognizing it.
Thank you for seeing
the resemblance.
That is Lord Gustav,
inspired by me, obviously.
I think you guys can
see the resemblance.
If you guys play
War Dragons, you're
going to see Lord Gustav.
I'm the main villain of the
game, obviously, as well.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
OK, so this game of
yours seems to have
been reasonably popular.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Yeah.
It's been really popular.
This is a graph
to represent that.
So this is the number
of battles per day
that we had since we launched.
So you see that
first beginning there
is right before we launched.
When we launched we get that big
spike getting a bunch of users.
After a few months we
got featured by Apple,
so we get that other
big spike over there.
That last spike that came
down was a special event
that we had where
people could battle
unlimited number of battles.
There were no waiting time.
So people did a lot of
battles during that weekend.
And the interesting
thing about this
is that with all those spikes,
with all that variation,
we never had any
meetings to say what's
going to be the impacts
in our infrastructure,
and how are we going to
handle millions of users
when we've had none so far?
And our servers are
going to explode
and we're going to have
to run around like crazy
trying to fix our
infrastructure.
We never had any of that.
Whenever we had those spikes,
nobody had to call anybody else
and come fix our servers
because things are exploding.
We never had any of that
throughout all those things.
Our infrastructure just worked
throughout all this period
of time.
Just so you guys have
an idea, this is, like,
War Dragons has been out
for roughly a year now.
And these number of battles
add up to 180 million battles
already.
So just so you have an
idea of the scale of this.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
OK.
So let's talk a little
bit about how it works.
What's the backend
infrastructure look like
and what's it powered by?
I know when you and
I first got together,
we talked about how
the primary part
of the backend
infrastructure is powered
by App Engine and Datastore.
Can you tell me about
this history there?
How you came to use
these two products?
The decision that drove
you to those things?
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Sure.
So this decision
was a little bit
before my time at Pocket Gems.
But basically the story
is that Pocket Gen
started as two guys had
an idea for a mobile game
and started building
that mobile game.
Right?
So they were two
guys that knew how
to build mobile games but
they didn't know anything
about server infrastructure,
even how to code for servers.
And at some point they
figured we need servers.
We need servers to collect
data from our users.
We need servers to make our
users do stuff together.
So they figured that and they
started to look for a solution
to their problem.
So they started
researching out there
for a solution to their problem.
And one of the things
that they bumped in to
was Google App Engine.
There were the
first few tutorials
out there for Google App Engine.
They started to do the
tutorials and try it out.
It was free to try it out.
They were also pretty
much broke at that time.
They were spending
all their money
in marketing for the game.
But Google App Engine fit
in their requirements.
It was easy to use.
So they started
building with that.
So it was kind of like
knee jerk reaction.
But throughout the six
years of Pocket Gems,
we never had a doubt that
that was the right solution.
As I said, we never had trouble
with servers exploding, people
running around trying to fix
because our users couldn't
play the game.
We never had a DevOps team.
Like we don't have
people around like 24/7
because things can explode and
you have to get to the office
and fix things.
So it paid off to us.
Like we sometimes
revisit the decision
to see if there's something
better out there, but so far
nothing jumped out.
It's been a good
solution for us.
When we started War Dragons, we
didn't even think about that.
That was not an
issue at that point.
MARK MANDEL: So it's
kind of something
you kind of fell
into, but it's been
so consistent and easy to use
that you've just stayed with it
all the way through?
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Yeah.
It was the right decision.
Even though it was a
knee jerk reaction,
it was the right decision.
Paid off.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
So just to set like the
stable set of context
so that we all have
the same understanding.
Hands up the people here who
have worked with App Engine
or who are familiar with it.
OK.
About half the room.
How many people here
have used Data Store
or are familiar with it.
OK.
Again, about half the room.
Great.
That's perfect.
So I'm just going to go
through some very quick
introductory parts
for these products
so that we sort of have
the same understanding.
These products are
what I like to refer
to as managed products.
What does that
necessarily mean though?
What it means-- and I think to
me and to many other people--
is the very direct
opposite of this.
I know I've done this in the
past-- I'm sure many of you
have too-- where
you're like, all right,
I think I'm going to
get this much load in,
so I think I'll need four web
servers, and maybe a database
for replication, and
maybe some other servers
to do some other things.
And this might be physical,
this might be virtual,
but this is really
kind of no fun.
You're managing your own scale.
You're managing
your own machines.
It's not really great.
When we talk about Google
Cloud Platform services
and managed services, what we
really want to be able to say
is, hey, Google Cloud Platform,
hey can you handle this for me?
And it turns around
and says, don't worry.
I've got this.
Yeah?
We don't have to worry about
backend infrastructure.
It doesn't matter
what our scale is.
It's going to handle
that whole thing for us.
So what does that
actually look like?
So App Engine is one of
Google Cloud Platform's
primary platform as a service.
So what does that really mean?
Essentially what that really
means is you write your code,
it bundles it up for
you to deploy it,
and it pushes it
up into App Engine.
And App Engine handles
those requests.
It handles taking that code
and running it in the Cloud
for you so you don't
have to worry about it.
It's generally a web based
application service system,
but it works perfectly
well for games
like we're looking at here.
The big takeaway I want
you to look at here
is that App Engine will
auto scale for you.
So it doesn't matter
how many requests
come in, it'll spin up as
many instances of your code
as is needed to run as much
requests are coming in.
So super, super powerful.
At the same time you
don't have to worry
about patches or security or
any of that sort of really
annoying stuff.
You just can rely on
Google services to do that.
On top of that, because it's
a platform as a service,
it comes with a whole bunch of
other services along with it.
We're going to talk about two
of those services here that are
used primarily in War Dragons.
One is task queues.
Task queues is a service
that comes with App Engine
to allow you to run
background processes.
It's pretty powerful.
It allows you to back
them up and queue them up.
You can run them in parallel.
It'll have retry mechanisms if
that code fails for any reason.
As well as that, we're
looking at memcache,
which I know you take
great advantage of,
which is a managed
distributed cache system.
If you've heard
of memcache, it's
been around for a
really long time.
It's pretty much exactly
as you expect it to be.
And there's a variety
of other services, too.
But we're not going to worry
about those too much today.
On the other side of things--
so rather on the request side,
but on the data
side-- we're going
to talk about Cloud
Datastore, as well.
Now the great thing
about Cloud Datastore
is it does sharding and
replication for you.
But it's a NoSQL managed
Datastore, as well.
So it doesn't
matter how much data
you put inside
Cloud Datastore, you
don't have to worry about
adding like replicas or mirrors
or anything like that.
And the big takeaway
here for this,
as well, is that it doesn't
matter how much data there
is in Datastore, your
read and write times
stay the same, which is really,
really, really powerful and so
important for gameplay
and making sure
your player experience is great.
OK.
So we've talked
about the products.
Great.
Wonderful.
Let's get into the nitty
gritty and actually
hear about how all the things
that power War Dragons work.
So when we got
together, we talked
about a variety of stuff.
We talked about
communication over REST,
we talked about matchmaking,
we talked about leaderboards.
Gustavo, you want to take us
through some of those things?
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Sure.
OK.
So let's start
with REST and JSON.
So all of our communication
with Google App Engine
happens with using REST
request, with JSON as the data
representation over HTTP.
So this is like
industry standard.
It works really well for
mobile because it's fast.
It's faster to render.
It's faster to parse.
It's very easy.
As I said-- industry standard.
So Google App Engine handles
that really, really well.
So that's where we chose to
do all of our communication.
We have some real
time communication
that we do over a
service called PubNub
because basically it was there.
It was a service that
had that real time,
so we didn't want
to rebuild that.
But all the rest
of the operations
that happened in War Dragons,
all the reporting and all
the analytics that we have,
and all the relationship
between players, all that goes
through GAE using REST and JSON
all over the HTTP.
That is also a great advantage
because HTTP works everywhere.
On mobile there's a lot
of problems with networks.
There's like crazy
proxies out there
and you go to a coffee shop
and there's another proxy.
And if you don't
use the HTTP you're
going to have a lot
of problems on mobile.
If you use HTTP with
REST and JSON it's easy.
It works everywhere.
MARK MANDEL: So there's
really no special source here.
There's nothing
particularly crazy going on.
It's just basic REST?
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Yeah.
Yeah.
The communication
is over basic REST.
If We can see-- oh, sorry.
MARK MANDEL: No.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Whoops.
We can see here, this is, again,
this is the number of requests
that we had right--
this is 24 hours when
we launched the game.
So you can see the number
of requests going up there.
A number of errors don't go up.
Like our error numbers
are pretty low.
Almost zero over there.
And, again, we didn't
have to do anything.
We didn't have to keep an
eye out for our servers
and see if we're going to
start to have more latency
or anything like that.
It just works.
Whenever something
like that grows,
you can see the
number of instances
that your game has
it's being served
by the number of instances
that Google spins up for you.
They go up as well and your
time remained constant.
MARK MANDEL: So you didn't
have to like rearchitect
your app as soon as you got
really popular or anything
like that.
It was all pretty much
easy enough to scale?
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO:
Pretty much easy enough.
We had some things
that we're going
to see later that we
faced, but nothing
that was like user facing or
that broke the game in anyway.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
OK, cool.
So I know you do some
particular interesting things
with App Engine and versions.
For those of you
who aren't aware,
one of the nice things
about App Engine
because its platform
is a service,
we take your code
when you deploy it
and we actually deploy it as
a version up into the Cloud.
This actually normally ties
directly to a unique URL,
as well.
This is nice for
testing, if you're
doing, say, smoke testing.
But in a web
application context,
normally you just send it
all to a default version,
which becomes like your
canonical or your production
version.
But I know, Gustavo, you
do actually something
really interesting here.
Can you explain that?
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Yeah.
So we do something
different with versions.
So versions is something that
usually people use for testing.
So if you're doing a
new feature or if you're
changing your website, you
spin up a different version
and you test on that version
and your production app
is still the same.
If you have multiple
developers working,
every developer can
have their own version
so nobody is stepping
on anybody's toes.
But one of the users that
we got from versions,
which is a little
bit different, is
so that we are able
to break compatibility
between our client side code
and our server side code.
So how do we do that?
So let's say in this example
here I have my client version
2.07 deployed and people
are using that version.
And so for that
version, we deploy
a version of Google App Engine
that is compatible with that.
So the Google App
Engine version 2.07.
As soon as we submit another
version of the client code
that breaks
compatibility, what we do
is we deploy another
version of Google App
Engine that is compatible
now with that version.
And because the clients
have different URLs,
they each communicate
with their own version.
So, for a brief period
of time, whenever
we release a new version,
we do have clients playing
in two versions of the game.
So if we had only
one server out there,
we would break every one.
We would need to
have crazy code that
handles like, if it's
this version, do this.
If it's this version, do that.
And we all know how
ugly that can be.
With this scheme that we use, we
don't have to worry about that.
We can just break that
compatibility right out
and it all works.
So then we have
those two versions
as people are upgrading.
At some point we force
people to upgrade.
And then what we
do is we basically
just take down that 2.07
version of the game.
As we do that, that URL
doesn't see that version.
So Google just redirects
you to the default version.
And the default version
is always the new one.
And then now all
that the client is
going to get is
that please upgrade,
your game is not
compatible anymore.
You need a new version.
But by that time everybody can
upgrade and then everybody goes
go to version 2.10.
MARK MANDEL: Great.
So I know matchmaking is
an interesting problem.
So if you aren't familiar with
games-- I'm sure many of you
are-- matchmaking is
basically just trying
to take two players from a pool
and pair them together so they
can have a game together.
I know it's an
interesting problem
because you don't want like
drastically outmatched players.
You don't want
someone to come in
and to be like
completely dominated
or to completely
dominate another player.
You want it to be such that
there at almost similar power
levels so it's very close
and they have a really
interesting game in that way.
How do you solve that problem?
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO:
So for War Dragons
we have millions of players.
And every player is going
to have a different level.
Right?
If you just started right now,
you only have a few dragons.
Your base has only
a few buildings.
But if you've been playing for
a year, as some of our players
have, you have a full base.
You have a lot of dragons and
a lot of very strong dragons
that you can battle.
So we don't want those two
people battling together
because one is just
going to crush the other
and the other is not
going to win any battles.
Right?
So you don't want
that to happen.
It's going to
frustrate your users.
So what we do is we
create basically buckets
of users with their
power level basically.
So we calculate your power.
We put people that have
that relative power
with the same bucket.
And whenever we need to
fetch an opponent whenever
a client goes, hey, I
want to battle someone,
we can quickly see
what is your bucket.
We go to that
bucket in Datastore.
We fetch any of the
opponents that are there,
we have all the
data that we need
is in that bucket
in the Datastore
and we serve that to the client.
So it's a really efficient
way to have people battling
people that have
their same power
level without having to do
big queries in a Datastore
to search for people.
So we already do that.
We do that in an
asynchronous way
so it doesn't take any
time for the users.
So whenever let's say a user
does a battle or upgrades
a building or gets a
new dragon, what we do
is we add a task
to our task queues.
And that task queue
is going to see, OK,
what is your power
level now and see if it
has to change your bucket.
So if it decides that it
has to change your bucket,
it simply takes you
out of one bucket,
puts you in another bucket.
And now when you battle
for the next time,
it simply picks you
of your next bucket.
So a really simple
solution to something that
would be really, really complex
in a normal database system.
So using a Datastore
and task queues just
became really simple for us.
Very easy and fast for
the end user, as well.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So I know you also
do special events
on occasion within your world.
I know you do a
conquer the world map
where you have guilds of players
to fight against each other.
Tell us about what
happens there.
I know you have
to render a world
map so all the people in the
game can see what's going on.
What sort of problems
are you solving there?
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Sure.
So conquer the world was an
event that we had for a weekend
where guilds-- which are groups
of players that band together
to serve as allies-- the
guilds would start everyone
with their own territory
in a map such as this.
And throughout the weekend you
would battle your opponents
and gain or lose territory.
And so the goal was to have
as much territory as you have.
This is what happened
during that weekend.
So you can see all the players--
all the guilds-- expanding
and contracting.
There was a lot of
strategy involved there.
People were trying to save
their dragons to the end
so the could conquer more.
So you see the green
team and the yellow team.
MARK MANDEL: I see
the orange team seems
to be doing very, very well.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: The orange
team and the green team.
That was the final result
of that weekend for one
of our divisions.
So what we wanted is
we didn't want just
to have something where
you draw a number,
you have like how many square
feet you have of territory.
We wanted users to have
a map, to have that sense
that they are attacking
and gaining territory.
So to doing that
on the client side
would be extremely
difficult for us.
So we decided to do
that on the server side.
So on the server
side what happened
was we have task queues
going in periodically
we're doing that
every five minutes.
So every five minutes
those task queues
would grab every data
from every battle
that everybody fought
during those five minutes,
recalculate territories, and
actually generate that image.
So this is for every division.
Division is a
collection of guilds,
which is kind of like
matchmaking for guilds
for that level of guilds.
So you can see
there that we have
those guilds which are actually
real names of divisions
that we have.
And every task queue
is calculating that.
One of the things
that we did here
which is a little bit different
than what task queues do,
whenever you add
something to a task queue,
if you add 100 things to a
task queue, Google App Engine
is going to try to run
that as fast as possible.
So if you have 100, if
you have like two servers,
it's going to try to spin a
bunch of servers, execute that.
When you don't have anything,
it takes down your server.
So this would be
something what you
would see if we had those
task queues running with what
is called the default scaling.
So every five minutes
you would see a spike
in the number of servers that
Google is spinning up for you.
Then it spins down.
You go almost to zero.
And then five
minutes later you're
spinning up a bunch of things.
So this is very inefficient
from a computing standpoint
and from a cost
perspective, too.
So, for this case, because we
knew the number of divisions
that we had-- like the
number of divisions
doesn't change
during the weekend--
we change that on
a periodic basis.
But we know it's not going
to change during the event.
And we know that we want to
render that every five minutes.
And we know rendering takes
an x amount of seconds.
What we do is we
use basic scaling.
So basic skating is you say,
don't spend more than x number
of servers for me.
So when you do that, then you
see something more like that.
So you still add 100, 200
tasks in your task queue,
but Google is not going
to spin up more servers.
It might spin up one, maybe not.
But you're going to see
something way more constant,
which is great for
your cost and is also
great for your computing
because computers don't have
to start and stop all the time.
So this is one of the things
that we did differently
than the default scaling that
everybody uses out there.
MARK MANDEL: So
this is really cool
because you knew exactly
how many divisions you had,
and you knew that
wasn't going to change.
You were able to take
advantage of that to get more
efficiency out of your system.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Yeah.
Whenever you have that
fixed computing power
that you know that's what
you need, using basic
is a better use of
your computing power.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Did I go forward?
I believe you also use
memcache and some other things
as well in that aspect?
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Yeah.
Some other improvements
that we did
to conquer the world map using
some of the Google App Engine
features.
So we used memcache
to cache the metadata.
So we had some metadata.
Like, for example,
where is your capitals?
So the client would
render the name
of the guild inside of the map.
So we had to have
where's that going to be
rendered on the client side?
So we had some metadata.
And we had a memcache
to catch that,
because it's really
fast for the client
to grab that information.
We also used something
called Google Edge
Cache which it's basically a
caching of your information.
So whenever we
generate that image,
Google asks us for that image.
We say this image can be
cached for five minutes.
So then we don't use that
computing power anymore.
Google Edge Cache
just takes care,
it knows that that image can
be stored for five minutes
and it just serves that.
So it's something that also
saves us money and makes
it way faster for the client
to get that image because you
don't have to hit a
computer to grab that image
and return that for you.
It returns from Edge
Cache almost immediately.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
So I know you also have a
leaderboard system so players
can rank themselves or be ranked
within a whole subset of all
the players.
I know that's kind of
an interesting problem.
Do you want to
describe the problem?
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: So,
yeah, leaderboards
are an interesting problem.
They seem simple
in the beginning,
but then you start
to see that it's
more complicated than it seems.
So leaderboards,
they basically need
to answer those three
questions for you
in a very efficient way.
So when a leaderboard,
I need to know
what is my position
in a leaderboard.
It needs to answer that fast.
And then it needs to answer
what are the people that
are around me, so I
can see like people
that I want to attack
later so I can jump up
on the leaderboards.
And it also needs to answer
like who are the people that
are in position 100 to 120.
If our users are paginating,
if they're scrolling,
you need to grab more data.
You need to be able to grab
positions at 100 to 120
really fast.
So it seems easy, right?
But as you guys
are going to see,
databases are not really suited
to answer those questions.
So let's see a little bit why.
So this is an example.
Actually this was one
of the leaderboards
that we had a few days
ago that I grabbed.
So let's say that you
have this database
and say, OK, that's easy.
I'm just going to create a
database with player name
and score.
I create indices for the
player name and the score
so it's easy for me to say,
OK, I want to see the Masse--
or I don't know how
that's pronounced.
I don't know why
I chose that name.
There a better names
for me to choose.
But OK.
So that Masse guy there, you
want to know its position,
it's easy for you
to check Masse.
But it's not easy to
know the position, right?
Because databases,
they basically
have to count everybody that
comes before that person
to know the position.
There's no position there.
So then you say, easy,
just add a position there.
Why not?
So you add up a column for
position and now you know.
Oh, Masse is number nine.
Easy.
Problem solved.
Not so much because what
happens when Masse wins a battle
and jumps up on the leaderboard?
Now you have this
weird thing here
where Masse is
actually number four,
but the position says number
nine, because the whole record
moves up.
You can't move partially.
So now you imagine already
what you have to do here.
You have to go and change
a bunch of those records.
You have to change all the
records between four and nine
there.
And that's a very
costly thing that you're
changing a bunch of records
that potentially other people
are changing.
So it's not an easy problem.
It's not as easy as it looks.
So when we started
building War Dragons
we started looking
for solutions.
OK, people had that
problem before.
Games have been out there.
Competitions have
been out there.
People have had
that problem before.
And, lo and behold,
we found some project
that Google did for
Google Code Jam.
Because Google Code Jam
is a competition of code,
they had a leaderboard of sorts.
And they released that
project as open source
for Google App
Engine, because that's
how they run Google Code Jam.
So, Mark, why don't
you explain to us how
about that solved our problem?
MARK MANDEL: Certainly.
So I had a look at
this code and I'm
going to explain
it fairly simply.
There's a link to the blog post,
which has a link to the code.
So if you want to go deeper
into it, more than happy to.
Essentially what it does
is it uses Datastore
to build a data structure
inside of it that's
able to answer these sort
of leaderboard questions
very simply.
What it actually
builds is a tree.
So the first thing you do
when using this code is you
select your range of
what your score could be.
Here I've selected an
arbitrary range of zero
to 10,000 as that's what my
score is going to land in to.
Then inside that
tree we're going
to pick essentially an arbitrary
number of nodes underneath it.
Here we're going to just
use three for simplicity.
And we're going to
split up those ranges
into each of those thirds.
So you can see like 0 to
3,000, 3,000 to 6,000,
so on and so forth.
And then so on and so forth
down the tree as we go.
And that's great.
And then what happens
is when we have
a score come in--
so someone gets
their score set-- it goes
in the tree in that range
that they fit.
That's cool.
But what we actually
do at each node
is we count up
how many scores we
have for each of the
children in a parent node.
So if we had 100 scores, it
would look something like this.
At the top we have 50, 25, 25.
If we continued
down the left, we
would add up all of
those to then 50.
So 10, 25, 15, so on and
so forth down the tree.
This is actually really
powerful for leaderboards.
If we want to ask
questions like, hey,
how many scores do
I have in total?
All I need to do is count
up the number of children
that I would have in the top
node, and that would be 100.
If I wanted to do
something like,
hey, I want to go find
the top 10 scores,
all I need to do is go down
the left side of my tree
until I've counted up
until I have 10 results.
If I had a score
that was 2,222 and I
wanted to know what
position that was,
I could just count to
the left of that tree,
and potentially upward,
depending on my position,
as well.
So we can answer these
sort of questions
really easily using
this data structure.
But, like I said, the notes
for this and the URL for this
are all at the very
end of the talk.
So if you want to dig
this into further,
this is a very simple
explanation of how it works.
But it does solve
this sort of problem.
I believe also App Engine, for
you, you use it in development,
you use it in a whole
bunch of other ways.
You love it that much.
Tell us about that.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO:
So one of the things
that we do that is the classic
way of using versioning,
we use versioning a lot
to develop new features.
So whenever a developer needs
to develop something else,
every developer has
their own version
of the server running out there.
It's really easy to deploy.
There's a desktop
app, press a button,
it deploys that for you.
And then you can test
your features there.
And whenever that feature
is properly approved,
you can then put it on master.
And then we have a process that
deploys that to our production
servers all the time.
So every developer
has their own.
Nobody steps on anybody's toes.
Classic use of that.
We do that all the time.
Another thing that we do a
lot is we like GAE so much
and it's is so easy
to develop for that,
that we do our own internal
tools for that using Google App
Engine.
So at some point War
Dragons grew a lot.
It was our largest team to date.
We had more engineers than
any other team at Pocket Gems
had before.
So we had to step up
our game in code reviews
and making sure that our
quality of code was good.
And we didn't have
any tools out there
that would serve us
the way we wanted to,
so we just wrote our own.
Like one of our developers
worked for a little bit less
than a week, wrote a cold
review portal for us,
and now we use all the time.
The whole company now uses
that code review portal.
We started adding
a lot of process.
And we all know that
developers hate process.
So what I did was
I built a robot
using Google App Engine
that just goes and does
the process for us.
We don't have to
care about that.
We just do a few things on
GitHub or on our ticketing
system, and the robot does
all the process things for us.
So I just wrote that in a few
days, rolled up a new server.
It's there.
We have a new server running.
Really, really easy.
We use that all the time for
our development tools, as well.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
So you love it so much for
building your production apps,
you use it internally, as well.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: I even
have some of my own.
Like I like it so
much that, oh, I
can do that for my own servers.
I was building some
little electronics thing,
and I needed a server
to serve information.
Oh, I'll just do it
in Google App Engine.
It's free for very small use.
So I just wrote my
own and deployed it
on my personal account.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
OK.
So it can't all be
sugar and spice.
There had to have been some
challenges and some problems.
We should probably
have a look at those
and see possibly what
dragons you had to slay.
Terrible joke.
Let's have a look
at some of that
and so people here can
learn from the lessons
you learned while you
were building War Dragons.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Sure.
So one of the
problems that we faced
is that War Dragons generates
a lot of what we call events.
So events are various things
that happen inside the game
that we can be
interested in to know
how people are using the game,
what time of the day people
play more.
So there are a lot of things
that happen in the game
that we save as events and then
we send that to our servers
so we can analyze
that data later.
But, as you can imagine, we
have like millions and millions
of lines of events coming in
all the time from our users.
And the way that the
Datastore costs are made,
you are charged by
operations in your Datastore.
So if you're saving one
event in your Datastore,
that is one operation.
If you're saving 100
events in the same table
in the Datastore, that
is also one event.
So we needed to figure
out a way that we
could save money on that.
Like instead of getting
information from a user,
we have 100 events there
and doing 100 operations
because they all go
to different tables,
we needed to figure out a way
to do that to-- I'm sorry,
Mark-- but to reduce a
little bit of our costs.
So let me tell you how we
did that using GAE zone
infrastructure.
So what we did was we
used memcache for this
because memcache is really
well suited for this problem.
It's very fast.
So what we did was
basically we create a bunch
of records in our memcache
that receive the events
from the players.
So these particular
records in the Datastore,
they just accumulate a bunch
of events of different types.
They don't care.
They just start to get
that information there.
At some point, memcache
has a size limit.
So at some point you
reach that limit.
When we reach that
limit, what we do
is we fire up a task queue.
That task queue now
grabs all the events
from that particular
record that is full
and it starts to sort into
a second level of records
in memcache, which
are, in this case,
particular to every event.
So if it's an event type
a, it goes to that record.
If it's an event type b,
it goes to that record,
and so on and so forth.
And when that
record is empty, it
can be reused by other clients.
At the same time, those
other second level records
are also going to become full.
When they become full, we fire
off another task in task queue
and now they put that
into the Datastore.
So now we turn what
could be thousands
of events that could be
thousands of operations,
now they do only one
operation because now they're
sorted by their table and they
go straight to that table.
And then they can be reused
for another operation.
But with that, we
were able to reduce
millions and millions
of operations
to a few operations per minute.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
So you were able to
use memcache to really
make that an efficient
and faster process.
And, as we've seen
before, you're
using memcache all over
the place, as well.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Great.
So one other issue
I know you faced
is Datastore data
contention issues.
For those that
aren't familiar, one
of the issues with
Datastore or possibly one
of the challenges
with Datastore is
there are some hard
limits around how fast you
can write or change
data on a single entity.
So if you have two
processes operating
on a single entity
within Datastore
at a given point in
time, it can turn around
and be like, whoa, slow down.
I'd like you to stop
hitting me so fast.
I know that was a
problem for you.
You want to talk about that and
how you ended up solving it?
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Yeah.
Data contention was
a problem for us.
So you can imagine that we
have some operations that
touch a lot of things.
So I'm going to give the
example of data reports.
So whenever you
finish off a battle,
you send that data
report to our servers.
And our servers need
to do a lot of stuff.
So it needs to award the loot
that you got from that battle.
At the same time it
needs to remove resources
from your opponent's record.
It needs to award you
metals so that you
can go up on the leaderboards.
So all that touches one record--
touches two records actually
in the players.
You have to actually
add to the war results
if that battle is part of a war.
You have to go and
add the war results.
You have to change
your leaderboards.
You have to change your
matchmaking bucket.
And then after you did all that,
now you respond to the user.
So one problem is
there's a lot of time
that the user isl not
getting a response
and maybe your game is
waiting on a waiting screen.
So that's not a good
user experience.
And the other problem
is that with this you
imagine with millions of users
doing that, a lot of them
might be hitting
the same record.
So if two people from the
same guild are battling a war,
they all are going to
hit the same war record.
And when that happens
you get data contention.
One client needs to wait
for the other one to finish.
And if they wait too
long, this operation
is going to fail completely.
So not a good solution.
So what we did was, again, using
all the resources for Google
App Engine, we broke that down.
So what we did was we do the
least amount of possible work
that we need to give a
response to the user.
So the user at this
point only needs
to know how much loot
you've got from that battle.
That's it.
So we do that.
And then we add a
task queue what's
called a transactional task.
It's kind of a task queue
but has special properties,
which is really nice.
We, at that point,
the award just
goes to one record over there.
Then we return to the
user-- so really fast.
And then we add a task
to the task queue.
That task is going to
do all those things
that we were doing before.
So it's still going
to remove resources.
It's still going
to give you metals.
It's still going to
add to the war results.
Still going to
change leaderboards.
Still going to change
your matchmaking bucket.
All of that.
And then you are going
to ask, but can't that
run into data
contention, as well?
You're doing a lot of
stuff into one operation.
And yes, you are right.
Thank you.
You're a very smart
audience here.
So that happens.
But when that happens, it's an
awesome feature of task queues
is that they just retry.
So if there's any
data convention there
and your operation fails, it
just goes back to the queue
and after awhile
it just retries.
So when it retries,
at some point
it's not going to phase data
contention, and at some point
it will commit all of that.
It takes a while, but it
doesn't change the experience
in any way for our players.
Those operations
don't change anything
in a meaningful way
for our players.
So they can be done
asynchronously.
They can take a while.
They can be retried.
So that's a really, really
nice feature of task queues.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
So you're able to take
advantage of the fact
that you have a lot of control
over how task queues can retry,
exponential back off, number
of retries, number of days,
et cetera, et cetera,
and so you can make sure
that this always happens.
It's just a question
of how long.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Yeah.
Task queues are awesome.
If you have bug in
your code, you can just
change that code and redeploy.
All your operations that
failed re-run on that new code.
So you can fix code on the fly.
And you can see the
size of your queues.
It's amazing.
It's really awesome.
We have some queues from
our old games there.
Just a fun fact,
we have tasks that
have been running
for two or three
years because we
have buggy code there
and because it's an
old game we don't care.
We just let those
things run there.
And they've been running for
like three or four years.
We have old tasks like that.
It's relentless.
MARK MANDEL: Fine.
Cool.
All right, so I'm sure
your code is perfect.
Mine often has some issues.
I know App Engine gives you
log aggregation by default.
But how do you use that?
I know you've got some
nice ways that you
use that with War Dragons.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Yeah.
So the log aggregation
that we get out of the box,
it's really useful.
It's really easy to use.
So this is just
the default console
log you can access
for Google App Engine.
And you have a
search box over there
at the top that
you can just search
for anything in your
request or in your headers.
So in our case,
for example, we use
that a lot to track down
problems that users are having.
Every user has a
unique ID, which
is a hash like ID, that
is really easy to search
for because there's
you're never going to find
another one in your request.
So whenever we need
to know what requests
are failing for a certain
user we just go there.
We search for their ID.
It comes up with
all the results,
and then we can dig in.
We can go in and see the
metadata, the proto payload,
we can see all the git
requests parameters.
You can add logging
statements to your code
and they will also appear here
as the logging statements.
If there was an
exception in your code,
you're going to
see that exception.
So it's a really,
really easy to use
tool that we use all the time
that is right out of the box.
We didn't have to do
anything to get this.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
All right.
Great.
So we've been talking today
about running games at scale.
But really what we're
talking about here
is running games at
scale without having
to manage your backend.
We've looked at two
special products here--
App Engine for scaling our
requests and auto scaling
those responses.
And also we've been
looking at Datastore.
We've beenl looking at
managing our scale of data
using Datastore.
But please remember
these are just
two products that exists within
Google Cloud Platform that
can help you build games.
We certainly have a
huge slew of products
that will help you build
games as well as a variety
of other applications.
We definitely have a huge
number of other sessions
still here at GCP Next.
So if this stuff is interesting
to you, please make sure you
check out all of them.
Finally I'd like to say thank
you very much to you, Gustavo.
I appreciate you coming.
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO:
Thanks for having me.
[APPLAUSE]
MARK MANDEL: If people want to
learn more about War Dragons
or Pocket Gems-- I know you're
coming out with a new version
soon-- where can they go?
GUSTAVO AMBROZIO: Oh, yeah.
I forgot to ask one thing.
Who here has played
War Dragons before?
All right.
So we have some people.
So hopefully that's going
to change right now.
So if you guys want
to play War Dragons
you can just go
to wardragons.com.
Awesome website.
There's a lot of
resources out there.
If you want to learn
more about Pocket Gems,
just go to pocketgems.com.
If you're an engineer
or a product manager
or a game designer or an
artist, come talk to me.
Go to our website.
We are hiring.
So come talk to me.
I'll hang out a little
bit more outside.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
And if you're interested
in App Engine or Datastore,
the URLs are up there,
along with the link
to the Global Code Jam code
that is there in the URL right
there.
And thank you very much to
you all for listening to us.
We really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]